basically my vivid memories in Haiti is
the best way to explain and think about
like the Godfather movie when they go
back in time and then it's the small
little village with the donkeys I mean
think about that but mine is you know
the luxury of the harvest it was just a
very poor community and no electricity
but a lot of drums a lot of native drums
which kept the energy going and I always
remember like my grandma a lot because
my grandma give us like a penny every
Sunday to go to church and sometimes we
took that penny and bought some candy
with it
but despite like how poor we were she
always found a penny every Sunday I was
like she always was like you know giving
his Karen so automatically I mean those
are some of my memories of Haiti the
rain you know the constant like
Africanism it was just an energy like
whoa God did not pass till I say no mm
capozella wool I didn't it was just like
it just feels so at times whenever I
feel like down I can hear like these
tribal sounds in my head and it picks me
up
when I first moved to New York coming
from the small village the tale was that
America the land of diamonds so we
thought that you know we would land and
there would be diamonds falling from the
sky you know that was basically the
impression and we got on a plane and
keep in mind that village I told you I
came from so now I'm on a plane and then
as the plane is going and we're coming
to New York City and I see a bunch of
lights and I look at my brothers you
know very rich the city of diamonds
we're rich we have arrived and so my
first impression of New York City was
like wow you know I think it's the first
impression of a kid that's old enough to
understand Disneyland and then they get
there and they're just like wow
my adjustment you know like coming from
Haiti and then growing up first in the
projects of Marlborough in Coney Island
you know it was a rough start because
there's a language barrier and
something's going on so on the first
thing you do is you try to learn the
language and try to see if you could fit
in with the culture and at the time what
helped me a lot was hip-hop music
because there was a lot of breakdancing
going on a lot of graffiti going on and
it was sort of like it starts off with
the stereotype of go back to Jamaica are
you yo man are you from Jamaica Haiti go
back to Haiti do you know where Haiti's
not no I don't know Haiti's so it's like
think things that kids go through and
then you're like I need acceptance I
want these people to respect me so I'm
gonna do their music better than him I'm
gonna do this better than I'm good
so as a kid you just start challenging
yourself and in a couple of years you
naturally pick up the culture and I
think what really helped me a lot was
the the the reggae music and the hip-hop
music
the creole language is the language of
my country haiti and why is this so
important to me because the natives be
Creole and then they have to learn
French right so somewhere along the line
I lost my French but I never lost my
Creole
it was sort of like it's important in
that you have an identity you know and
what I mean by that is you know if
there's a language that has been spoken
like you know your mom speaking your
grandma speaking your grandma's mother
speaking your mother's grandma's speak
it and then you don't speak it what what
end up happening is you know you just
broke the generation gap because your
kids not gonna speak it and it's very
important when you have a language
that's a language from where you're
where you from and it represents culture
so I could never lose my crayon because
that represents the culture the strong
identification with Haiti comes from my
parents yes I come to the States at a
young age but inside of the house the
culture that we was raised with is the
culture of the islands in what we came
up with my mother always say well
outside of the house
you can be as American as you want to
but when you get in this house you
Haitian you in Haitian food you talk
rayou you listen to music online in Elle
but it actually was a great thing
I decided to do what I do when I was 2
years old had two years old you know I
heard the sound of a drum playing in the
village and I'm and I found my own drum
and just picked it up and started
playing volleyball volleyball local abou
caliber oh cool the worst song ever
written by Wyclef Jean but it actually
started a vibe professionally I started
doing what I was doing when I I turned
like 13 years old
and not only because a lot of times it
surprised people what I do because they
say aren't you a hip hop artist like how
do you know about Bach how do you know
about Art Blakey how do you know about
crystal girl how do you know about Pink
Floyd well understand that you know my
background and naturally what I grew up
with was music in the church and then
going to high school I got introduced to
jazz and and from the 9th grade to the
12th grade all I did was study and play
jazz all day so for me um it's just then
I turned 18 years old and got my first
contract with Atlantic Records big beat
at the time they just released Nelson
Mandela and I did a record car out of
the jungle and it was dedicated to
Nelson Mandela and I got with my group
The Fugees and like 1989 which was like
a high school band for me and basically
with the Fugees I went on to doing my
first CD the first city was called
blunted on reality was me prized and
Lauren why did this thing work it worked
because you had three individuals from
three different styles of music
Lauren taught me about R&B because at
the time I was more into like church
music reggae or rock you know prized was
just a rock head and so Lauren would
come
stylistics what's that you know and then
she would play and then I would
automatically learning the first CD was
called blending our reality it basically
tanked and in the second CD we went to
my basement my uncle's basement me and
Jerry one that got together Lauren and
prized and created a classic that's so
basically 22,000,000 that CD was done
inside of a basement so if you do a
music and your basement on your garage I
always say that's the best place I think
that's where you're gonna get your pest
material from or the bathroom
the Wyclef Jean music is eclectic music
Wyclef represents eclectic music
eclectic music I've been doing this
music since I was a child and I said I
will refuse for anyone to put me into a
box whenever I want to listen to sell
your cruise I will when I want to hear
Pink Floyd I will when I went here Bob
Marley I will I want to hear nirvana I
will I can and I will
I want to listen to jay-z i will biggie
smalls to part and this is the ipod of a
kid today
so the Wyclef Jean music is just
eclectic music it's called good music
my influences range from like Jimi
Hendrix to Bob Marley to Marvin Gaye and
then one of my favorite like singers you
know when I hear him I could identify
with his voice you know a lot a lot of
people would be like man how is Johnny
Cash you know what I'm saying
I like Johnny Cash a lot like my dad was
a minister and stuff and just growing up
in the church and I grew up with a lot
of Christian rock and so that's some of
it
the Haitian music one of my favorite
bands is called Bachman experience and
Bookmen experience represents the true
roots and the culture of what Haitian
music is to me you know that band is a
band when I hear it and they say there's
a connection with Haiti and Africa I
naturally could feel that connection it
represents not seen the translation for
Garcia's roots when you listen to that
music then you understand the connection
of you know where the Haitians are from
and why the rhythm sound like that
it's it's the natural music of the
country and then the young generation to
listen to a form of music which is
called compound music and compound music
is more like there's bands like Jaco
music there's bands like T Vice fans
like Karen me that's sort of like you
could say like there's barb Marley and
then there's dancehall you know what I'm
saying so that's the best way to
describe it like there's what I seen and
then there's compound so the younger
kids are definitely more into the compar
which is a traditional like form of like
dance music from the islands created in
Haiti which was definitely has a lot of
influence on what I do
my music evolved I mean at this point
you know what I'm saying it's like you
know my role model you know I'm saying
like I'm a young Quincy Jones you know
like what I mean by that is that's my
blueprint you know and I feel like my
career is just getting started you know
I'm into a lot of scoring music now I
like the sounds of scores you know I
want to do like big soundtracks for
movies you know I want to like develop
more of the Y clef sound the sonic sound
and get my own label carnival house
records and start to find great talent
develop it and help expand it
in terms of personal music I would love
to collaborate with Lauren would prize
definitely whenever they're ready I'm
always ready as a producer to get the
Fugees cracking what's holding the
Fugees back lauren hurry up
when I recorded the CD in the basement
we was able to sell 22 million copies
because the internet had not evolved you
know the way that it did now I'm if it
did the kids would probably would
probably sell 2 million copies because
the kids would be able to go and
download piece by piece and get all the
songs the content with all of the
technology that's out there
you get everything quicker there's
quicker access to everything and
everything is basically free through the
internet I mean from movies to music to
whatever you want for a kid to actually
go to the store and pick up the actual
CD they got to feel like it's a
PlayStation game coming out or something
you know and but the thing is I say
while that's going on creative music
only sell so whether it's through the
technology whether it's through the
people come in to the live concert you
know you can't slack on your music or
your live shows because the sales that
you want are not matching because you
can get those same cells with the live
concerts so what you got to do is us as
musicians true musicians we have to work
four times harder because on to go
platinum to go double platinum to go
triple platinum you basically have to be
out there half of the year promoting and
travel in different parts of the world
unlike before it was a little easier
like you could just do the CD and if
people like it you know enough people
will buy it because they didn't have
access to it that's where the technology
changes
I think you know the music industry will
always be relevant in the sense of you
know you need artists you know and but
of course I think that they felt like on
if the music industry knew what
technology was gonna do I think that
with the web and everything I think they
would have adapted and bought those
companies and actually made those
companies part of the music industry
today
today it's a little different with the
artist back in the days we had artist
development there was a budget for
artist development so if you basically
find an artist you got to have the money
now to develop it because basically a
label is not going to give no money for
artist development they want the artists
to come in fine-tune and ready to go so
this is where you got a you know pick
and choose exactly what you want to work
on
I think on whether if it's Lindsay or
Paris you know like people be like well
why they're doing records you know what
I mean I think music is self-expression
everybody's entitled to express music
however they feel and they want to
express it and I think it's up to the
person to decide what they don't want to
listen to you understand you got a
choice Wyclef Lindsey what do you want
to listen to you know you got a choice
Paris Alicia Keys what do you want to
listen to and um I think at the end of
the day um you know you can't knock
anyone's hustle because at the end of
the day everyone is just trying to find
what works for them best
hip-hop is the culture rap is part of
hip-hop spoken word which is poetry is
part of hip-hop yes the lyrics that I
write are definitely poetry it's arm you
know you sit and you know you look back
at it and what it is is its
self-expression
definitely
I think hip-hop culture is a
representation of communities so
wherever you go like you go here you go
to Pakistan you go to Russia and
wherever you go and you look for the
hip-hop culture it's gonna be an
expression of what that environment is
going through and the kids are probably
gonna be talking about the topics of
what's going on within that environment
so you know you might be in the States
I'm gonna yellow this rap stuff's all
about bling-bling and gangsters and you
know but going to the environment and
talk to these kids and ask them when's
the last time they came and built a
school here when has they put new
buildings here when they had so the kids
stay on a corner and they fantasize
about this luxurious lifestyle that we
portrayed because it's an imaginary
world of what we wish we had because you
know we can't see past that because they
are not really helping the communities
and bringing in people to really help
change these communities
yeah I think there's two forms of
imaginary world there is the imaginary
world where you know you watch the TV
and you think you can get it like that
that's killing the kids that's wrong you
know what I'm saying
because I was imagining that I was gonna
play at Madison Square Garden but I was
working in a fast-food restaurant
okay kids so that's the truth which
means like don't think like you see a
cat out there and you see the blings and
the cars that all of a sudden they just
did that and then you can't get that
you're like okay well let me go and you
know sell some more this crap you know
I'm saying cuz this rappers say he's
just so crap when the rapid until you so
cranky in selling crack no more and if
he does he's going to jail you
understand hey after you told you so
cracking the lyrics he's back in a nice
mansion so you go ahead and want to
emulate that and then you're in jail for
20 years then call me
I think the culture of hip-hop is
spreading through the world and it can't
it can't slow down because what happened
is every place there's communities and
all these communities have their own
expression of hip-hop and what they want
to talk about I think rap music in the
States
you know we're in a situation right now
where we trying to figure out what it is
you know what I'm saying because every
other person is a rapper so what's gonna
determine you know your life as a rapper
every other person is a rapper every
other person is talking about Jews every
other person talking about champagne
every other person is talking about the
rims and their grills that's every other
person so like the lifespan of a rapper
now is probably eight months so we're
like yo where's the actual rapper's go
you know what I'm saying so it's like
like you know you still got the Commons
you know you'd have you still have
people that represents this side see I
represents his side little Wayne has a
side you know common Kanye you know what
I'm saying
Lupe Fiasco just came and claimed the
sign so I think you know it could get
interesting but we just need more
variety so that it could be sustainable
because if we don't get more variety
then what's going to end up happening is
it's just gonna get boring
in 15 20 years you know you know hip-hop
hip-hop will always be around the
culture will be around but it will be in
a new form of a new expression and it's
probably gonna go back to melodies and
songs
the issue of race no matter how much we
want to like ignore it you know I'm
saying we have to talk about it because
that's how we're gonna move forward I
feel that there's no generation are not
prejudiced at all the majority of the
generation you know what I'm saying but
then we still got like you know 10%
that's trying to hold on to the past you
know what I'm saying like you're black
you know I'm saying you're Asian you're
you know you're white you're you know
what I mean you you've seen a lot of the
hate crimes is that that has been
happening you know what I'm saying and I
feel that right now where we are with
the world we have to realize that we
really want people and what I mean by
that is not in a cliche way but if you
check your blood you check my blood it's
really the same blood at the end of the
day theoretically speaking so you know
what our face was always like you know
as a Haitian there's always a stereotype
and a stigma which goes with us you know
what I'm saying like okay you're a
Haitian you're a bold person you're
stink you bought aids these are the kind
of stigmas when I look at you and I'm
like you don't have a clue you're
ignorant you don't know what's going on
you understand what I'm saying to you
and these are the stigmas that our fight
for as a Haitian everyday to basically
say y'all need to get past that BS and
let's deal with some of the realities
and facts of the world
I think Obama gave a great speech on
race I could definitely relate to it
because you know coming from Haiti you
know you have like what's still called
the upper class and then what's
considered the lower class you know what
I'm saying and and sometimes you know
because someone from the upper class
makes it the lower class want to hate
and you say where the hell is this hate
coming from like why do they feel a
certain way well they feel that way
because there's nothing wrong with being
part of the upper class but they take it
back two generations or three
generations before and that hate is
coming from the fact of they're saying
well our super super ancestors were
slaves you know and you know we
basically feel like we're in the same
position so a lot of times when you see
hate in the issue of race you've got
action stuff where actually is this hate
coming from no one is really making this
hate up like there was one time where
people was really getting lynched there
was really one time when there was sick
and dogs on people like this that's
Martin Luther King he got shot like this
is for real like there's a time where
people was angry you understand and
similar to Obama I mean what I feel is
that
you know there's Moses right and then
Moses could go but so far and then Moses
look they said Josh we'll go ahead
handle it so I feel like we're the Josh
was it today so I feel like being the
Joshua was that today
we got to get past the old situation and
moving forward for it to work we all
have to feel like we won race I don't
know the last time you check the economy
they don't say okay well you're not you
losing your house because you're white
or you're not losing your house because
you're black or cuz you're yellow no
they're like yo you can't pay for this
house we're take we all in this thing
together so we need to get past this
race issue and start dealing with
reality
I think the new generation of Joshua's
like we're not done but we need to start
and I think where we start at is
unifying and really being one and really
not waiting for things to be in a bad
position to really talk about it to
really understand that we're leaders you
can pick up a pen and write to Congress
you can email if you don't like certain
things from the beginning because there
is a real Constitution and they need to
spend respect the generation that's
coming up and that we're dealing with
that right now I think that's very
important that you exercise your rights
before something goes down and that's
when you feel like you want to deal with
it then people don't take you seriously
because they're like oh you only you
only apply action when you feel it's
necessary well I feel that action is
necessary all the time there's so much
things that are going on in the world
from Africa to Asia to back in your own
hometown where you're right now you're
sitting in a community you might not be
happy with the community maybe you don't
want them to break that building down
right there because that building
represents a monument something for the
community well talk about it write to
the mayor you understand
maybe you need more funds for the school
you don't like the way this school is
being treated you look and you like well
where's these funds for education get
together rally with the kids and talk
about this did this this you have this
is what we have to do to start moving
forward
I think that when people look at Obama
they have to stop saying okay it's a
race you know what I mean because what
happens is when you look at Obama he's a
man so it's like when you look at
someone you gotta get you know past the
level like look at the debates he's an
educated man he has the gift of speaking
to people he has the gift of going
anywhere around the world and actually
being in a room with someone and looking
at them in the eyes and having a
conversation what I love most about
Obama and this is why y'all gotta get
past this whole race
period cliff said so what I love most
about Obama is Obama says we got to get
off this high horse that we are and
start to deal with things the wreck and
I think to move forward as a race and as
people we have to start doing that
well I'm encouraging the Joshua
generation to definitely go out and vote
for Obama that's beyond an endorsement
I'm the song if I was president I get
elected on Friday assassinated on
Saturday buried on Sunday then they go
back to work on Monday as if nothing
happened it was a song that was inspired
by a conspiracy theory you know sitting
back looking at what's going on in the
war the billions of dollars is being
spent and the fact of whenever someone
is coming in to actually present truth
they shoot them down so then I put
myself in the position of you know if I
was president they'd probably take me
out the way they took Martin Luther out
or the way they took Kennedy out but at
the same time we should strive to be the
president meaning that the best that we
can be tell the children the truth
well I am is a great producer you know I
call him the little clef and
I had I have respect for him as a
producer you know and when he did that
yes we can my respect for him though
went to level 300 because this is what
it's about when you have kids like that
that's see Obama and then they just get
inspired so yes there is room for music
and people say is there room for music
and Pollack takes us that oh you mean
Paula tricks so there's room for music
and social issues but whenever we decide
to talk about social issues you call
them politics we call them politics
right we said leave the politics for the
politicians and let's deal with these
social issues
yearly ye le we have a foundation and
the website yearly why here eat or it's
a foundation I started a few years ago
and we started it because we wanted to
bring self-esteem back to Haiti and
currently 7,000 kids have scholarships
we started something which is called hip
hop on Sunday hip hop for health mobile
clinics going throughout Haiti giving
people HIV test giving them condoms but
through music there's also a children
prison program where we've went into
these prisons where there's kids
introduced chest took over the prisons
put more beds basketball courts and
these kids are reading and every time I
go down there tears come to my eyes cuz
I knew I was in the beginning a lot of
these kids was in gangs most terrible
violence you can think about and yearly
is actually the movement is really
working and it's it's the greatest thing
is when I look at a kid and I noticed
that I can rise his self-esteem because
someone rose my self-esteem that's why
I'm here
that's yearly
well the first thing is we have a
documentary coming out which is called
cry Haiti and this is my work on the
ground for the past three years I didn't
leave the ground until I felt that the
people on the ground understood what we
was doing and was training so I kept
going back and forth back and forth and
now I feel like we have great a great
team on the ground we have a great NGOs
but to get it it took three years of me
going back and forth to Haiti a lot of
times when you start in foundations for
it to really work you have to be
hands-on for the first couple of years
and and right now it's a natural will
it's moving
well the gap that the celebrity fills is
that the celebrity can reach millions of
people like that
so the fact that they lend a voice are
they named to Africa
it makes millions of people that
wouldn't even care about Africa look
towards what's going on in Africa
I think you know there's um I think a
celebrity period doing any form of
charity is is a great thing because a
celebrity don't really have to do
anything as much as you wanna think they
do they're celebrities so they could
actually just chill and don't do nothing
but the thing is
but then there's those celebrities that
don't only lend a name they act on it
and of course the bar is rose so high
for these celebrities people like
Angelina Jolie she's she been in Haiti
with me Brad Pitt I mean look what Brad
is doing at New Orleans you know what
I'm saying
real initiatives George Clooney like
going to these places looking with the
eyes and learning and then I'm bringing
the information back to the American
people I think that's where the future
is headed
the high-rolling style that's portrayed
on the television is basically a dream
meaning that if you have a dream it can
happen it could come true you know in a
way it's good for kids to see that but a
lot of times I feel like all right if
you're telling the high rule is I think
this story should start from the rags to
riches because when you do that then
it's a sense and it makes sense but the
idea of just flossing you know hundreds
and millions of dollars and then jumping
on a plane and then a boat and then kids
really think that you know it's your
boat what I've learned is let me tell
you kids something this is what I've
learned through my years the people with
the real money don't do any of that
stuff
nine times out of ten they're in a room
you won't even know who they are
unless you hear people talking about
them so the thing about it is when
you've seen all this high rolling and
you like I'm going to tell you what a
tycoon said tycoon has billions of
dollars the tycoon said why cliff you
know what's funny about you guys you all
want to be us and we want to be y'all
and that's like the best way to explain
it you understand
well I think that you know first of all
the women that are portrayed like that
in the videos they want to be portrayed
like that in the videos or they wouldn't
come to the video shoot so that means
that there's a gang of women out there
that wants to be portrayed like that you
understand what I'm saying to you
because the women that don't want to be
portrayed like that they won't be
nowhere by those videos you understand
what I'm saying to you and I think that
the idea of degrading women and making
women look like there are they're
hoes they're nothing they just you know
it's not a great example you know I'm
saying because we all got a mom you know
I mean and we wouldn't want to portray
our moms like that you see what I'm
saying so the bottom line is you have to
be conscious of what you portraying
because when you end up having a
daughter I'm sure you ain't gonna want
your daughter jumping around like that
and acting like that so you have to make
sure that you put a thin line and if
you're doing a video like that I think
you should basically do it in a smart
way like you could be way more clever
with it
opposed to alright now time to drop
champagne on our head you know I think
it's corny I think the smarter way of
doing it is check out my video the
sweetest barrel baby and you see how you
want to portray women get those strong
women in those videos
I could definitely relate to Dave
Chappelle I mean I basically I think I
left the music industry for like three
years a lot of people's like worldwide
collapse doing and it basically looked
like I was out of the scene but I went
back to Haiti started doing charity work
clearing my mind because sometimes the
industry can be it's it's a lot of
pressure because you know they expect
you to produce and every time you get a
good one they expect another one then
another one then another one and
sometimes now you start to get tired
because you're like just trying to
appease people opposed to you know just
concentrating on your heart
that's a good question what do I think
about Reverend Wright and what he said
Reverend Wright served in the military
correct was here marine right
Reverend Wright has seen what he has
seen he has was called freedom of speech
do I speak like Reverend Wright no do
Obama speak like Reverend Wright no
Reverend Wright speaks like Reverend
Wright he speaks as he speaks as Obama
speaks as he speaks Obama has his views
I have my views you understand so
meanwhile while people are saying you
know Obama don't have a chance in
Pennsylvania because you know you know
people will vote for Hillary because of
the Reverend right I would just say if
we're gonna put everything out let's
just put everything out so you have two
things to weigh here
I know political adviser but let me give
you a little logic Reverend Wright
controversy
fire under snipers so you waited fires
on the snipers Reverend right
controversy I really think about what
you're really saying and if I was you I
will vote for something that's honest
and that's not portraying something else
at the time and purely just talking
about what's out there that we all talk
about we see it in the media it's clear
you understand what I'm saying
I think that you know certain remarks
that Reverend Wright made were racist
remarks but there were racists on what
he's seen you understand I don't feel
that he's a racist I felt that there
were remarks made on the racist issues
that he's seen coming up so it's like
you know do I think he's a racist no
does he well if he's not a racist cleff
why did he make these racist remarks
these remarks are made on situations
with portrayed racism like they're out
there so he's speaking the same way that
someone else speak but they won't
necessarily speak out and say it